if you haven't seen my previous video on
the ixions and the clay laksu
then you can find them in a playlist in
the description of this video
in this video we will discuss some of
the ideas and philosophies
that frank herbert attempted to explore
with his creation of these two groups
to understand we have to go back
thousands of years in the dune
universe's timeline
in the 10 000 years prior to the opening
of dune
humankind had for the large part
maintained the basic tenets of the
butlerian jihad
open use of computing technology carried
significant social and legal
consequences
the official punishment for those found
to be in possession of or to have
constructed such
technology is death as a result various
groups formed throughout the empire
new technologies were created to replace
the jobs once done by ai
the most well-known and significant of
these technological innovators in the
dune series
are of course the tla laksu also known
as the bini clay laks
and the ixians both groups blur the
lines of what is generally thought to be
accepted
based on the teachings of the orange
catholic bible which came about after
the butlerian jihad
and has had significant influence over
the course of humanity since
it stated thou shalt not make a machine
in the likeness of the human mind
among other things ix is named so
because it is the ninth world in its
solar system
the fringe world is governed by an
unquestioned technocracy
ultimately ix resisted the most
devastating effects of the violent
butlerian jihad
which forcefully expunged all thinking
machines from the human universe
during the time of shadom iv the wise
knew that the ixians stretched what
would be considered appropriate
by the prescriptions of the jihad but
the technology worked
so a blind eye was often turned frank
herbert
with the invention of the ixian
technocracy is making a statement about
the potential
of unchecked technological progress just
because we can
do something should we lato the second
the god emperor foresaw the problem with
the ixians where no one else did
he knew that continued progression of
technology
specifically weapon based technology
unchecked by mindful humans
was dangerous and often deadly
there is an early episode of star trek
the next generation
where the enterprise encounters a planet
that deals with a similar idea
no one is on the world and we learn that
it was once inhabited by two warring
civilizations
all that's left of them is their weapons
we come to find
out in the episode that their weapons
technology had been their
undoing automated self-replicating
drones had been given the command to
eliminate
all enemies at all cost and it was far
too effective at its job not unlike the
hunter seekers of dune
in the first dune book paul the tradies
encounters one of these devices
and it takes all of his training to
defeat it what lato the second saw
eventually would come in the future
would be much much worse and it would
arise from the unchecked labs of the
ixians
a hunter seeker that would continue to
improve upon itself
to the point of the development of a
kind of machine
prescience it would not stop until all
human life was exterminated
the seeking machines would be there the
smell of blood and entrails
the cowering humans in their burrows
aware that they could not escape
while all the time the mechanical
movement approached
nearer and nearer and nearer louder and
louder
but later the second prevented this with
the creation of sionna
she was immune to press against sight
and would spread these genes throughout
the whole of humanity
by the time of the honored matries
though the ixians of the old empire had
helped to undo the guild's monopoly on
space travel
with their creation of ships that
required no human navigators to pilot
they were clearly headed for a demise
this
is confirmed by the observations of the
mother superior o'draid
in the book chapter house tune no matter
the outcome
ix is dying witness no great ixian
innovations in
centuries mark them well they are
products of a dying society
it is naive to expect any bureaucracy to
take brilliant innovations and put them
to good use it is plausible however that
whatever ixian threat latel foresaw
would
not arise from the ixians of the old
empire
but from the ixians of the scattering
who fled the empire eons ago
the potential of innovation outside the
old empire was tremendous
especially with no one to enforce
restrictions on technology laid out by
the butlerian jihad
who knows what dark things might have
taken form in the scattering
brought into existence by the hands of
intelligent but thoughtless humans
though the ixians dabbled in technology
which stretched the limitations of the
butlerian jihad's tenets
the benny playlax stretched the very
idea of what was considered human
over time through selective breeding and
more precise genetic engineering
they have altered their appearances to
an almost elven form
they are short with pointed faces and
sharp teeth
in chapter house dune it is implied that
the benny plalax adopted such an
appearance
in order to appear intentionally
repulsive to those
outside their race the tlalac zoo were
extreme
xenophobes bestowing the name pawinda
upon all
off-worlders we have discussed the clay
laksu several times on this channel
to reiterate the tla laksu race is split
into two divisions
the masters and the face dancers the
axolotl tanks are a hidden division
possessing no will of their own they are
the remnants of the plalax of females
it is remarked upon in the series that
never before has a plalaxu female been
seen
the face dancers were also essentially
slaves of the tlalaksu masters
they were created with the ability to
copy the appearance of others
and later versions of the clay laksu can
even adopt personas
along with some of the person's memories
the tla laksu masters
never truly died every so often they
stored a copy of their memories
if a master's body was destroyed he was
recreated as a gola
and the memories are restored this like
the majority of chile laksu genetic
manipulation
is made possible by the axolotl tanks
somehow the tlalaksu are able to program
them with genetic
information they can produce an entire
human
from a single cell agola itself is not
technically a clone
because golas are made from cells of
those who have already died
in the later books the tlaxu also
discovered a way to produce the spice
melange from axolotl tanks
this coupled with the ixian innovation
of spiceless space travel all but
destroyed the guild's monopoly on space
travel
the secret of the axolotl tanks is
heavily guarded by the beni clay lacks
though the benny jesuit sisterhood does
eventually discover
the secret of gola production though the
mini jesuit are repulsed by the
technology
trying times forced their use to become
necessary
it can be clearly seen in my opinion
that the continued progression of the
mini playlax down their specific path
would have had an inevitable outcome the
bini jesuit though they manipulated
bloodlines
were very careful to remain within the
bounds of what was considered
human the tla laksu isolated themselves
from the rest of the human empire
whilst the bennie jesuit mingled their
dna the plalex who did not breed with
and hardly ever interacted with
outsiders the telaelaksu were on a path
towards something very
inhuman frank herbert is not just making
a statement on computing technology
but all of it just because we can invent
something does it mean that we should
just as the ixians are evolving towards
a state of inhumanity
so are the clay laksu in the end it is
not the technology
but how and why we use it does it enrich
our human experience or diminish it
if you've been watching this channel for
a while then you've likely seen this
passage before
but it has never been more relevant than
now when later ii takes siona into the
desert they briefly discussed the ixians
and technological innovation what is the
purpose of those journals
a nixian machine records them they are
to be found on a far away day
they will make people think and nick
seeing a machine
you defy the jihad there is a lesson in
that too
what do such machines really do they
increase the number of things we can do
without thinking
things we do without thinking there's
the real danger
look at how long you walked across this
desert without thinking about your face
mask
you could have warned me and increase
your dependency
lato stresses mindfulness the power of
great technology wielded by the careless
is more dangerous than many realize
that is the truth that countless science
fiction authors like frank herbert have
seen throughout the years
technology is not bad it is even useful
very useful but let's take care that we
don't go too far
in the wrong direction
who cares about this anyway you were
supposed to put out your chapter house
dune video
jesus christ where'd you come from you
know that whole thing about technology
is [ __ ] right
organism where have you been the last
six or seven weeks i've literally been
right here i'm your prisoner ugh do you
ever stop [ __ ] complaining jesus
christ i'm a living unconscious being
you can't just do this to me
no where the [ __ ] is the chapter house
meeting organism
guys thank you so much for watching make
sure you like and subscribe for more
quinn's ideas
and definitely follow me on twitter link
in the description for all of the
twitter and ticks